and
our next guest is nigel topping his
official title is
uk high level climate action champion
for the united nations climate
conference the cop 26 which was
planned to take place in november 2020
in glasgow uk and it has been postponed
to 2021.
now 2020 was to be the year of
climate uh in a way the comet of climate
action uh
really five years after the paris uh
agreement when not the moment when the
world would come together and take stock
of
uh whether there is there has been
progress or or not and what kind of
progress
uh and maybe even uh up the level of
ambition
uh towards uh you know reaching the
targets set in the paris agreement
towards 2030 and uh
2050. and then the koit 19 pandemic
arrived and
shook that that momentum it did not
distinguished it
but but in the minds of some the health
crisis
and the economic crisis are reasons for
pushing the pause button
on climate others instead
seem to think that or the the
pandemic has actually shown the
fragility of the basis of our
uh economic system and of our society
and therefore we should not
try to go back to a pre-pandemic world
but we should
try to accelerate the transition towards
a cleaner and
better future and that's what we're
going to talk about
about climate change and system change
with our guest
nigel topping welcome to ted 2020
hi bruno nice to join you uh
i think that we need to start from a cop
this is the the centerpiece of the
international construct
uh when it comes to the discussion about
uh
climate change but it's definitely an
institution uh that's not very familiar
to too many so tell us
briefly uh what it is and especially why
the glasgow cop 26
uh is so important first of all to
explain what cop stands for right
because
it's not obvious it stands for the
conference of the parties which means
it's the
conference of all of the parties to the
un climate convention
um and and as we all know paris was
a real breakthrough because paris was
the the moment when
all the countries of the world and and
the the the un process for climate has a
very high
consensus threshold everyone has to
agree so it's very
almost it's basically every country has
individual veto right so it's a very
high consensus
so paris was the real breakthrough when
everybody agreed on the long-term goal
and the mechanism
um the reason that glasgow's so
important is that it's really the first
the first real test of the paris
agreement like will the paris agreement
work
is it working because what what the
paris agreement did was it
did a couple of things it it gave up on
the idea that nearly 200 countries can
agree everybody's targets
imagine the number of combinations
that's just it's kind of ridiculously
complex
and that had been the process before and
paris kind of gave up on that
idea but instead empowered every country
to set their most ambitious targets
but realize that you won't get enough
ambition first time around
so the second thing that paris did was
said and every five years we'll
review everybody's targets and everybody
will come back with a new
plan so this is what's happening right
now as the first countries are starting
to come up with their their revised plan
chili's
um submitted their south korea's made a
commitment we're starting to see
them come in so paris will be the first
real test have we
as an international community been able
to ratchet our ambition that's what
we'll find out in glasgow
uh your job high level climate action
champion that's not exactly a mainstream
job title so what's your role in there
so in
the other thing that was special about
paris was that for the first time in the
international process
there'd been a recognition that not just
national governments but businesses
investors
cities um states and regions remember
california is the fifth biggest economy
in the world
and cities like new york and london have
much bigger economies and populations in
many smaller countries
so all these big real economy actors
have a real role in the politics
and in the economics of action on
climate change so they were invited in
not into the legal process
but into the informal process to lend
their voices um
as as the un system recognized that
those all those actions were going to be
needed
so in paris as well as the paris
agreement this role of the high-level
climate action champion was created
to work with those communities of
businesses investors cities states and
regions
to keep driving ambition alongside the
national
process so there's a kind of feedback
loop between the two
but in terms of the legal aspects of the
discussions those are still national
uh it's the political aspect that is
more all-incompetent
the legal agreements are entirely
between national governments so my my
job is to work with what are
sometimes called non-state actors or
non-party stakeholders
in the in the un system but of course
who all we all know that politicians
look to
citizens they look to investors they
look to um
businesses they don't want to get too
far away from them um
and of course cities and states and
regions have a lot of power in
in many countries as well so yeah number
one the people i work with
don't have a formal role but they have a
big political voice
yeah but that that puts you in a
position where you have you know one
foot
close to government and another one
close to the many people working on
asking for action on climate or pushing
back on action on climate
how do you create productive meaningful
dialogue
um i mean i think first first of all i'm
meeting everybody where they
are right it's very easy i mean i spent
the first part of my career in
private sector it's very easy in the
private sector to think that um
politicians don't understand
the real world because you know they
don't understand the private sector but
when you actually work with elected
politicians you realize that's a
different kind of real world right
actually having to go around and get
votes raise money be elected maintain
your position so that you can have power
to
change the system that's very i think
first of all it's being
um realistic in meeting people
where they are and then i think i spend
a lot of my time acting as a kind of
translator or
or a bridge between different worlds
particularly
particularly paying attention to early
signals of change because
both incumbent businesses and incumbent
politicians
are very wary of moving too soon to
change so they tend to look at what the
majority are thinking all the time
which means they're kind of cognitively
blinded to early signals of change so i
spend a lot of my time
searching for and amplifying and
pointing to early evidence of the kind
of change which we know is inevitable it
has to happen
but the politicians and business leaders
have not necessarily been paying enough
attention to
let's let's go back in a second to those
early signals but uh
you know when people from the outside
look at the multilateral effort around
climate they may have the impression
that it's something a bit uh
dysfunctional stuck it's a stock process
uh you know and there is maybe little
hope to
to to make progress uh we think of you
know the cop 25 in madrid
last last november where in any case if
we followed it through the media
it looked like uh at least a partial
disappointment
but when you offered when you were
offered this job you you took it so i
guess you have a different
opinion on that well i didn't tell you
because i thought it was a slam dunk i
mean it's a real challenge right we are
talking about the complete
re-engineering of the global social and
economic system
because energy's at the heart of
everything we do so it's not but i do
think that um
you know the media there's a phrase in
the media that
that refers to a cognitive bias that we
have to look at negatives we get more
excited and pay more attention to
negatives
the media have a phrase that if it
bleeds it leads and i think that's the
story of madrid
you know in madrid um just a year after
the
ipcc that's international paddle on
climate change the the panel of
scientists
and published their report on the uh on
the difference between a 1.5 degree
warming and 2 degree warming which
basically said that
it's a massive difference and for every
fraction of a degree we have
significant human and economic damage so
let's it really
reset all of our thinking to we've got
to go for 1.5 degrees which means
getting to zero
by 2050 in the one year between
that being reported and madrid suddenly
we had
hundreds of businesses and cities and
states and regions and lots of countries
saying okay we're gonna so we had a
massive ratchet in ambition
during the madrid conference
the continent of europe the entire
trading block one of the biggest
trading economies in the world committed
to net zero by 2050
and yet the media coverage was dominated
by protests on the street
which which are real and which reflects
real
discomfort unease anger right on the
street and
the failure to negotiate some small bits
of the paris rule book because that's
mostly what's being left to negotiate
they're important politically because
that reflects our ability to agree
but they're not as material as the
entire european economy to kick
out to net zero so i think there's
always it is a very complicated process
right it does require collective action
that's difficult to achieve
but it's not black and white and it's
not failing we have a significant
increase in ambition since paris and
it's still not enough
and by the way the science is kind of
running away from us as well because
every time we look at the science
it gets worse and in fact next year now
with the delayed cop we'll have the next
the sixth
set of reports start to come out from
the ipcc and i think we all know that
that's going to raise the
level of risk again so i'll put more
pressure on to ratchet ambition
before glasgow so before
the pandemic there was a growing
momentum around climate
from politics to business to citizen
youth activists in the streets and and
so on
but now the world is going you know he's
exiting the acute phase of the pandemic
possibly but entering an economic shock
a global economic shock
uh and and and at the same time the need
for radical cuts in greenhouse gas
emissions is not going away but
now many people are basically saying
let's postpone talking about climate
let's you know roll back regulations we
need to restart the economy
we can think of climate uh later and
restarting economy of course it's an
urgency so how do we restart the economy
without forgetting the the urgency
of of the climate crisis
i i think i think there is a i mean
there is there is a
i mean you know there is a sort of truth
to the
sense that one must concentrate on the
most immediate problem first right so i
think
it is true and understandable that
ministers and leaders
have focused more on the immediate
health immediate health crisis and less
on the long-term climate crisis because
nobody wants to be told that their
long-term health is being secured whilst
their short-term health is
well people are literally dying um so
the real issue is how how do we come out
of this um and i there's a couple of
things i think
i i think that that we've learned
generally there are some people who are
head in the sand on this that we really
should take the science of risk very
seriously
um and we we understand the science of
the risk of climate change very
very well and it doesn't get better
right we already have locked in a lot
more temperature right so we have
locked in more floods more droughts more
wildfires
more typhoons so it's not a problem
coming somewhere else
in another generation it's coming to us
now in our communities all around the
world
and it's getting worse but we also know
economically that the solution
to climate change is a driver of
economic
growth and a driver of jobs so so it
would be real folly now to
ignore the science of risk and to take
stupid
economic decisions to invest in the jobs
that are dying anyway
instead of accelerating the transition
to
the jobs which will last which will
build wealth and which will deliver a
cleaner and healthier
world for us all to live in so that so
yes that ideological battle is being
fought now i mean
it seems to me that most countries i
think we'll hear um
you know shortly from the european union
on some of the details of their green
new deal
um are very much looking to invest in
cleaning
the economy rather than taking a step
backwards if you
take you know one one sort of example of
a political folly of trying to revive a
dying industry would be the
um you know coal mining in the united
states you know president trump's
famously invested
by saying he's going to bring back coal
he hasn't
because it's no one will invest in coal
because it's not healthy and because
it's dying economically so actually
we've seen coal-fired power stations
shutting under trump just as fast as
under his predecessor who had a very
different
ideology so i think the combination of
the health and the technology and the
economics means that there's only one
direction of travel
and those those countries that invest in
the past
will end up wasting their money and
being uncompetitive
and so they'll lose jobs in the future
as well i think i think there's
generally a sense of that although
that's still being uh
contested in in in some countries but
not in many
uh i'm curious when was the first time
that
you yourself realized that climate
change was real
i mean viscerally in 1987 i
in in in greenland i was in a i was a
21 year old mountaineer and on an
expedition
and we were um
doing some scientific research on the
snout the end of a glacier where the
glacier
carves into the sea it's in the east
coast of green and the cirmulic fjord
it's a very big glaciers one of the main
ones draining the east
coast ice sheet um and we got to where
we were supposed to be doing the science
which is
where on the map the end of the glacier
was and all we could see
is it's a big glacier all we could see
was like two kilometers of
open water with bits of ice floating out
to see him this is before digital maps
right so you know the map was the truth
so this was
a real we were like really shocked
through like something's we thought we
must have made a terrible
navigation there it took us a while to
realize that we were in exactly the
right place but the glacier had just
moved back 20 kilometers
so it was really shocking um that's
really
stuck with me there's never been any
doubt in my mind that
um climate change is real because i've
once you've seen something
physically up front like that something
yeah
yeah i answered the question because i i
i guess that many of us
uh uh know and acknowledge that climate
comic crisis is real and and we need to
change but we're also
you know embedded in really complex big
uh uh
systems the one that run our life the
the the economy and thinking about
changing system is really
uh sometimes it's hard and sometimes can
be overwhelming
now you you mentioned before you have
been in the private sector
you weren't just you're a system
engineer so in the past you've worked on
large-scale manufacturing systems and
optimizing factories optimizing supply
chains and so
and i know that in your current role
you've actually set up your teams
to work on systemic change so can you
give us a specific example but
you know in some details about how do
you think about that how do
how do we think about changing complex
big overwhelming systems
yeah um i mean it is hard because it can
be overwhelming right because big
complex
systems are big and complex so and most
of our life we
break things down into small chunks and
work on one
part of a system and that's how we can
get that's how we get stuff done right
you can't you can't work at the level of
the whole system you've got to choose
you know one direction to work and and
do that but when you're when
when we're confronted with the need to
transform systems i think the first
thing is to have a sense of the hole so
to have a sort of map of the hole so
um so with with my team we look at what
all the different
levers are so we take something like the
the system that produces
cars which leads to a lot of pollution
um
in cities and a lot of co2 through as we
drive cars and burn
gasoline and look at all the different
levers that are influencing that system
so it's not just
the the technology and the policy though
those are important
but also what are in how are investors
thinking about that how are
how's the next generation thinking about
that um how
are um cities thinking about that so we
see
um and then we look particularly look
for for early signals of
of change so um you know the kind of
the evidence that cities are starting to
create um carbon-free zones or banning
combustion engine
or the or that some companies who exist
by
leasing cars are starting to commit to
go 100 lease plans my favorite example
is
nearly 2 million cars in europe they've
committed them all being electric
by 2030 way before most policymakers
have said
um and way before most car companies
have committed but they're in
an early adopter because they see that
so so i think
seeing the whole system and looking for
all those different um
not being too precious about knowing
exactly what the future is because
you're always surprised i mean most
people working in climate change i'd say
we're very surprised by the
sudden upswing of youth voice through
the the school strike
movement which has massively changed the
politics but no one was predicting it
so so being aware of things that as they
pop up and and
and scanning and then looking at the way
they they um they interact with each
other
so so for example young people becoming
more aware of climate change
um starts to really affect the
employment contract so you find the
smartest engineers now
don't want to work for companies that
haven't got the house in order on
climate change because they want to be
solving problems
not contributing to them so we keep
hearing now that the best young
engineers are interviewing the companies
that they're applying to
to make sure that they're purposeful
enough to want to commit their
their skills and their intellect to them
so you're looking for those kind of
feedback loops
um that shift the whole system over time
so what you're saying also is that the
future is not something that's that and
we walk into it right the
the signposts or the future kind of
keeps shifting because
every time one of those decisions that
you mentioned from cities from companies
etc
uh uh is taken then it gives permission
to others to
be more ambitious or to change their
practices or also
is that what you're suggesting this kind
of dynamics
yeah and this sort of dynamic way of
thinking about the future is really
important because mostly we think very
linearly and incrementally and so we're
always surprised at how fast things
even when we know we're always surprised
we're still surprised so the way i
describe it i
live on the street with 10 houses the
way that most
thinkers about the future try to predict
how many
people on my street will have an
electric vehicle in 2030
is they look for public commitments to
buy an electric vehicle and they find
out that nigel and tracy down the street
so they say two people out of ten have
committed
so it will be 20 they completely ignore
the fact that the cost is coming down
that when nigel buys his tesla um people
are going to look at it and say oh can i
have a drive and then that's going to
encourage them to buy it so actually by
the time we get to 2030
eight or nine out of 10 are gonna have
bought so we're so
we were very bad at you know this idea
that just adding up what people
think today tells you what they're gonna
do in the future it's kind of it's kind
of silly but it is
it's quite prevalent i always think also
that um
the the way that we think about the
future really really matters and my
favorite example is i just read the
um history of the moon landing and you
know when jfk said that we're going to
land on the moon
lots of people said it's not possible in
particular some of the best
mathematicians in mit said but we don't
even have
the mathematics to calculate the orbital
trajectories to land a vehicle
on the moon so that's quite common
that's quite often the
response of experts actually when that
when a bold target is put
there is to say why it can't be done
whereas what jfk did was say
i don't care we're going to the moon and
eventually those same
um mathematicians said okay well if
we're going to go to the moon we better
figure out those
orbital dynamics and they did and we
went to the moon so
i think this there's some you know
experts sometimes are very good at
saying why we can't do things we need to
insist on the future being the one that
we want so that we
unlock some of the creative juices of
experts and engineers around the world
so we when we met for the first time a
few months ago you
told me a story about shipping and how
now the trajectory of global shipping
may change because of this dynamics of
one decision or this to another is
another can you can you elaborate on
that
yeah it's until fairly recently like say
a couple of years ago
um there were a series of sectors that
were collectively known as the hard to
abate sectors
in other words the ones that we haven't
figured out or got round to yet so it
was steel
cement shipping aviation
heavy heavy heavy trucking so we're
making good progress on renewable energy
and
cars but pretty much everything else
we're saying it's hard to abate
and then about two years ago the energy
transitions commission published a
report
showing how we can get to zero in all
those and and the report
mostly i was one of the commissioners
but most of the commissioners were ceos
of energy or
heavy energy using companies so as soon
as that report was published it changed
the perception and around about the same
time mask the biggest container shipping
company in the world said okay we commit
to being a net zero shipping company by
2050.
no one really believed that it was
possible until that report and that
now we've had daimler the inventor of
the combustion engine commit to net zero
2039 we've had
steel and cement companies commit to net
zero um
and then so then you start planning
battlefield if we've got to get to net
zero shipping by 2050
maersk realized they're going to have to
have a zero carbon ship on the water by
2030.
that's a long lifetime asset right
you've got to you can't
flip that the capital base very quickly
so now we have a coalition called the
getting to zero coalition which is
shipping companies fuel companies ports
countries
who've realized that if we have to get
to zero by 2050 we have to have the
new ships on the water by 2030 and then
you kind of go well we have to
have them built by 2027 because they've
got to be tested you have to have them
ordered by 2025 designed by 2023 so you
you kind of got to know what you're
going to build pretty much next year
is it going to be hydrogen ammonia fuel
cell so
you that really puts pressure on getting
the some of those decisions some of the
investment done now so 2050
in many sectors is not a 30-year luxury
it's what we do in the next five years
it will dictate it
absolutely one of the
one of the silver linings possible
silver linings of cop36 being postponed
to
to next year is that is not going to be
caught into the vortex of the u.s
presidential election campaign of
november
2020. talk to us about the us and the
role of
u.s politics in the climate discussion
maybe maybe we can put it this way
is us going to succeed in slowing down
action for the rest of the world
well yes i mean yes is a
key player in terms of the economy and
its emissions and um
and was one of the key actors in getting
us to paris
the relationship between the usa and
china who came out early with a joint
statement and then the usa working with
india was was really crucial
so um the decision of the current u.s
administration to withdraw from paris is
really
it's damaging it damages the
multilateral system it
it kind of legitimizes
bad behavior in the multilateral sense
so it's definitely not
helpful but i think um i think the
jury's still out on whether
um that really has the negative effect
that it sounds like on the surface
because remember america
has two redeeming features in the sense
of climate ambition one is it's a
federal
system so a lot of power is is delegated
um so we have many many states and
cities
and um and companies and universities
have all created an alliance actually
called we are still in so they said
you know the u.s federal government
might be saying we're out but we're all
still in so they're really building
momentum and that's that's growing all
the time
and the other thing of course is the
market economy and as i said you know
the market really is
voting with it with its dollars i think
the really damaging thing for the usa is
most likely to be its own
competitiveness i mean i really worry
for the health of the us
automotive industry the us detroit
famously
got um the first oil prices badly wrong
in the early 70s
and continue to invest in
heavy inefficient cars
and as a result a lot of americans are
driving small light efficient european
japanese korean cars today
i fear for detroit that if if detroit
doesn't stop colluding with the current
administration and rolling back
um uh fuel efficiency standards then by
2030 the rest of the american market
will be
electric um chinese and european cars
and they'll be
you know with this possible exception of
tesla um the detroit
um will just not exist as a car
manufacturing centre because they're
just strategically getting it so badly
wrong now
china's the biggest market in the world
europe similar size
to america america can't dictate the
technological trajectory for personal
mobility it's being decided
elsewhere and it's going electric and
it's going really fast and so american
companies are
missing out so i think i think american
politics at the federal level is not the
only
game in town you look at look at the
distributed um
uh politics at the state and city level
and i say california is the fifth
biggest economy in the world and has
got one of the most ambitious plans to
to clean up its economy so
the jury's out and um of course but
you're right i think you are right that
it will be helpful that the
cop will not be the week after a
presidential election because that would
kind of suck all of the
media attention out of what goes on in
glasgow
let's let's hear from whitney if there
are questions from the audience
we we have one question from uh shahani
ghost does the world have a
responsibility to help rebuild after
catastrophic climate change consequences
such as the recent cyclone in india and
why is that not happening in a more
global
globally coordinated way
well that's a really good question um i
mean in a way
the the inequalities
um around the around climate change are
at the heart of the political
difficulties of getting agreement over
the years
i mean there's a there's a phrase that
all negotiators know in the climate
negotiations called common but
differentiated responsibility
it says that um yes it's a collective
responsibility but some countries cause
the problem much more and some are
suffering
from it much more so some so and it's
the same within countries right we have
vulnerable communities within well
within within
um wealthy countries as well
so does the world have responsibility i
mean i think i think i think the world
has a responsibility to
um do the best job it can to prevent
catastrophic climate change and that
feeling of collective responsibility was
very much in the room in paris when the
gavel came down it was a sense that
actually collectively we had risen to
our better we were being our better
selves we were not being
driven by um
factional fighting but we were actually
doing what was right for the whole
it's hard to maintain that right i mean
you look at the i understand the world
health organization has a budget that's
equivalent of
of of one hospital in the states so we
haven't created a multilateral system
that is very well resourced
to deal with situations like that um
so that's the main reason that it
doesn't happen in a coordinated way is
because it's really hard because the
world
is set up dominated by individual
sovereign states and getting people to
agree to do things multinational is very
difficult
that's why the parish agreement's so
important one of the things that was
being negotiated in the run-up to
glasgow is
is the the provisions for what's called
um loss and damage which talked to
exactly the kind of issue around
how does the world collectively support
countries that are going through
crises like the the the cyclone in india
right now
that sounds great and um i'll continue
to monitor the questions behind the
scenes and i'll be back with some more
thank you whitney uh you mentioned china
uh
nigel uh it's an interesting case
because
it's a leader on solar for example but
at the same time it's building
coal plants you know week after after
week week it kind of embodies the
paradox of energy which is that
significant expansion of renewable on
one side but it doesn't really flatten
the curve on
on on carbon uh on the other on the
other side
why so and what can be done
well it's it's complex right i mean it's
a very big
complex country um and
um it really has led in um
solar wind electrification i mean you
know the the
the the buses which marcela was talking
about the um
running on the streets of santiago are
built by byd
big chinese electric bus
company um so the the um
leading the way in many of those
industrial transitions but it's also you
know a huge economy with a huge
um energy need um they have been
significantly reducing the
um carbon intensity of their economy and
they've committed to doing that by 2030
and must
think that they will have turned the
corner by then
um i think that the
ultimately that the market will take
care of coal in china i mean coal in
china if you actually look at the stats
coal fired power stations in china
are running at very low utilization
levels because they're also built such a
lot of renewable power
and the renewable power has zero
marginal cost basically whereas the coal
power has
it's it's complicated by the politics of
employment right because
china has employs a lot of people mining
coal and a lot of those communities
don't know what they do i mean we've
seen them we've seen that social
dislocation in
in the states in virginia in my country
in the north of england and south of
wales where coal mining communities
have been through very painful
transitions so a lot of the work that's
at the heart of the
energy transition now is to think about
what we call just transition like how do
we actually take
manage the transition from a human point
of view it's not just about getting the
technology
right if you have a whole community
where every you know where half of
people work in coal mining
you can't just say to that community
coal mine
coal is bad you have to do something you
can't do
so i think that's what that's what
china's grappling with it's also
grappling with the
the risk of social unrest from dirty air
in cities which is pushing in the
in the clean direction um so so
my sense is that we might see some
knee-jerk reaction
in terms of keeping people working of
building some qualified power stations
in china that we had thought were going
to be off the books but that quite
quickly
that that will that will change
interestingly you might have seen that
china's just said it's not going to use
gdp growth as its main
planning indicator of success because at
least for a short term yes
exactly yeah so so be very interesting
to see so i i think that um
you know china is on a trajectory to
wean itself
off coal remember even in europe germany
one of the most sophisticated economies
in the world has said it will keep
burning coal until 2038.
similar drivers right they have they
have a they they they
mine and burn brown coal it's the
dirtiest form of coal
so they've had to negotiate with the
communities and with the unions a time
frame which most of us think is
woefully long i mean i would like to see
germany get off call by 2030 but also
understand it's
politically very difficult again if
you're a politician in
in in that community where most of the
jobs are cold you can't just turn up and
say you're all out of a job
in three years you have to manage a
process absolutely
nigel let me ask you one more question
and then we bring in whitney and then
there is a final question but uh
uh i want to go back to those early
signals of change that you mentioned at
the
at the beginning you know because if you
look at the media and film and social
media and
and uh books there is a lot of doom and
gloom about climate
uh but then there are a lot of good news
in a way that go
almost unnoticed uh give us maybe a
couple of examples of of
of those early signals of change or
those good news and why do you think
they're important and how to think about
that
well first thing that says don't spend
too much time reading all those gloomy
books
right it's really important because you
once you've read one you've read them
all
right if we don't tackle climate change
it's
really bad right read it read a little
bit of science read the ipcc summary
report for policy makers
right satisfy yourself that the science
has been done rigorously but don't then
because because from the bad news
alone no solutions come right you have
to turn that in their motivation to
to act and so you have to go from
despair to hope right you have to choose
to act in the belief that we can
um avoid the worst of climate change we
can't avoid everything it's already in
trying we're already seeing it
and if when you start looking there's
there's evidence
all over the place that we are waking up
that we are getting more ambitious the
technology costs are going down
millions of young people striking is a
positive sign right that's young people
saying
we're holding our parents generation to
account and you know that that makes a
difference i've seen policy makers say
this has changed the politics forever
i've seen ceos being asked by their 14
year old daughter what are you doing
about it
daddy that's a that's a very powerful
signal um the cost of renewables
continue to plummet you know solar costs
come down 80 the last 10 years
battery storage coming down 17 every
year within a few years
electric vehicles are going to be
cheaper than i don't know why anyone
would buy a combustion engine car by
2030 i think
that even the oil companies who've been
in denial for a long time are now
starting to make net zero commitments
south korea has been financing um
coal fired power stations overseas um is
still doing so but has just had a
government elected on a net zero 2050
platform and they've committed to ending
so if you start looking if every country
every
community every sector you can see signs
that um
we're starting to see exponential change
and the pace
is growing and i think that by the time
it gets to glasgow really the case will
have been made that this is inevitable
and it's
accelerating and if you don't want to
miss out then you better you better get
it get with the program pretty quickly
let's see what whitney has from the
audience
sure we have a number of questions
coming in from the audience um our first
one here is from al gore
what do you think is the most likely cop
26 at this point wouldn't it be better
to have it during the heat of the
northern hemisphere summer going forward
hi al thanks for the the question um
i don't know um i've i've been working
with my team on the contingency of
somewhere between may and november next
year
i think we'll find out very soon the
decision is made by a body called the
cop
bureau which is a subset about i think
11 members
of different countries representing the
different blocks of countries
the moment i'd say i think it's looking
more likely to be later in the year
um we have local elections in the uk in
may that makes it difficult
june is the european football
championships which means
and glasgow is one of the host cities so
the the policing two major events like
that i think is impossible
so so we're starting to look later july
might be possible august
you know nobody nobody in europe works
in august so that's impossible then we
start running into the un
program in september and we've got to
fit a g7 and a g20 and so
i think the smart money's probably on on
the autumn um
but we'll know i think within a week
i'll
and then we can all plan concretely and
stop speculating
and uh we have a ton of other questions
and just uh
in the interest of time we'll just ask i
will test one more um we're having a
little bit of a tech glitch with showing
some of the questions so i'm going to
actually read this one out it's from our
community member
judita eisler um how can we meaningfully
connect grassroots efforts and these
large-scale system approaches how do we
engage
both meaningfully well so i think i
think
grassroots is part of the system right
and they are connected you can't be not
connected to systems change
so everything that grassroots movements
are doing when when people take to the
street and say we want
more climate action that systems change
right
when when when a 15 year old asks um his
or her
father or mother who's the ceo of an oil
company what are they doing about
climate change that system's changed
so never underestimate um what small
actions can do it could be
it could be 10 million kids on the on on
the streets
um or it could be you know one student
asking their university why they're
still investing in
companies that aren't taking climate
change seriously all of those have
ramifications um and and
so never think that because you're only
one small person or your grassroots that
you don't have systems impact
those those noises um when they're heard
that's the trick to breakthrough often
have a disproportionate impact when ceos
start realizing that
young people that university students
don't like the trajectory their
company's going in so they won't buy
their products or they won't work for
them
that has a profound effect so yeah you
are a systems change agent if you're
if you're a grassroots activist so keep
it up
nigel let's maybe end on a question that
has to do with uh
the individuals who feel overwhelmed by
this
uh necessity to change big systems uh
because people do wonder now what can it
do as an individual
can you share maybe one of two ideas
about you know what what what is the
individual action plan to contribute
meaningfully to
fighting climate change i mean first of
all it's entirely normal to feel
overwhelmed right i mean i i i i first
knew that i was probably going to be
going into this job
just before the madrid cop and i got
formally appointed at the beginning of
february this year
but i do remember walking around madrid
with like 30
000 people there all trying to solve
this interactive problem and feeling
extremely overwhelmed
um and i have a lot of agency and i at
the heart of this process so
i'd say don't feel bad if you feel
overwhelmed but just don't get stuck
being overwhelmed right there's lots of
books and with ideas of what to do i i
think
there's two levels you can think about
this one is your own footprint
and remember we need to halve in 10
years so just don't think about it as
tomorrow
in 10 years you can shift your
electricity supply to being fully
renewable you can actually do that in a
few days
um if you do own a car you can decide
you're never going to buy another car or
your next car will be
a shared electric car would be an
electric car so the combination of
renewable
electricity and electric car that's
taken a massive chunk
you can shift anytime you upgrade any
big piece of capital equipment like a
boiler or a stove you can shift from
gas to electric so you're going from
fossil to now renewable
power um you can look at your diet i
mean you know
um intensively farmed meat is is is a
big part of the problem so you can look
at your diet again there's lots of you
can you can read a lot about how diet
you don't have to go off meat completely
um sustainably farmed meat but a lot of
you know a lot of red meat is bad for
your health and it's bad for the health
of the planet
um so there's a there's a you know if
you're if you fly a lot you can use this
technology more maybe say i'm going to
have my flights in the next
five years right so you have you have
individual power over all sorts of
things
the other thing is you're a member of
all sorts of groups if you're if you're
a student you're in a school or a
university
ask the question about the school
university's plan to get to net zero
what it does with its
investments if you have a pension ask
your pension fund how are they working
on this
if you're if you're an employee in a
company ask the company where it's net
zero
plan is and i know that a lot of the the
the educational tools and the work of
ted countdown will be helping people to
engage more grantly but there's always
something you can do and there's always
people who want to do it
with you and you and never give up right
because you never know when one
one more question is the one that
finally gets the head office and has a
change of policy so
keep keep prodding away
nigel thank you thank you for being with
us for this hour and sharing your
knowledge and uh
your uh uh your challenge really
with uh with us uh good luck for that
love to you and your team it's
reassuring to know that
there are people like you and your team
working on this
thank you nigel thank you very much
thank you pleasure